what up guys
it's the end of a work day for us it is
a friday which means we get to live our
lives yeah it's gonna be fun we've been
hustling so hard on the barbell side we
can't wait for you guys to see all these
new launches restocks happening that's
if you've uh ordered like brown sugar
boba that's coming your way and we have
some more stuff coming dude it's been
nuts
as you all know and if you've been
listening to the news there's a bunch of
supply chain shortages everywhere
because of covet and
it's been nuts but now it feels like
everything's coming kind of back to
normal and like supply stuff is getting
fixed
whatever that's what we've been working
on this entire week and it feels like
some [ __ ] forever but today again
it's friday so stoked the first thing
we're gonna do
is
we're finally gonna get some junebe boba
and i'm [ __ ] excited because as you
guys know i live in vegas we yet to we
have yet to get one out there
so anytime i do come back to california
i really want to go
and get some damn jumbie um but more
than ever i want to get it because it's
guava season and i haven't had anything
guava
in a few years to be honest with you
what is going on with the guavas why
have i not had a [ __ ] guava in so
goddamn long why haven't we had guavas
babe
i love guava you know guava is like one
of my favorite fruits you can't you
don't love it more than me
i'm taiwanese i grew up on it well you
like the white guava i like the mexican
pink one i love white guava i like
pink guava too okay i'm gonna move over
here because this pool is being [ __ ]
weird um
but yeah that pink guava
and this
okay i'm gonna move further over here um
and let me just explain my appearance
because it's been [ __ ] up and i'm very
much aware that i look [ __ ] up okay
i'm sorry that you have to stare at this
for a minute but um because we've been
just freaking on a ground on a hustle
especially when we come out to
california we get a little bit more time
because grandma is watching taika and
taika plays with his cousin
um that we train our asses off still
running the get lean program um and then
from there don't be grossed out but we
don't take a shower and we come straight
to work and we just [ __ ] grind it out
for the next few hours until it's about
like five and then uh we go home so
this
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show but you know what
i'm so happy to report that as of today
i've lost 10 pounds according to the
scale and i will preach this over and
over and over again
um the scale is not the best indicator
of weight loss it's always going to be
the mirror
because if you see what you like and you
like what you see
and you're on the right track obviously
if you want to go a little bit more
scientific and a little bit more
accurate you can do a dexa scan uh which
we did do
at the beginning of running this program
we have a whole youtube series on it um
on our barbell brigade youtube channel
so if you do want to follow along
because we do release a new video every
single week please go ahead and do that
because it's been fun because we added a
little extra layer um as you know bart
and i we're very competitive people so
we started a competition of who can lose
the most body fat at the end of it but
again um because we do have to take a
dexa scan to get that specific
information um
during the middle of the series we do
weigh ourselves with the scale so we
kind of have to follow whatever the
scale says just to kind of gauge who's
kind of winning um
so
check it out to see because because i
think we just uploaded the first
check-in
which is like the four-week mark this is
a 12 week program so the four week mark
go check it out to see who's in the lead
but again i just want to brag and say
that i've lost 10 pounds since then i
hope you're able to see it
he doesn't care he's so used to me
being weird
what do you mean
how can we look like you're just in
trouble
i had a really genius idea to write it
down i don't want to just lose out on a
million dollars like that
[Music]
well i'm talking to myself again
and you
again i'm sorry for this
i'll do better
what you got there cutie pie
oh this is my keys
i hate you i hate you with all of my
being why
why on your [ __ ]
in your arms
in the
arms an angel
no i'm just kidding so these are our
limited edition hardcover copies of the
get lean
and if you guys follow our barbell
brigade instagram if you're not you're
losing out because we've been doing
hella giveaways
and so these are going to
our top three winners that won the
limited edition hard cover giveaway yeah
because i even wrote you can only buy a
digital product yeah because we want to
make it easier to carry with you on the
phone and uh we printed out for
ourselves but we just looked so cool
that we're like let's make some limited
edition hardcovers and i even wrote
personal notes to them
which is really cool i didn't want to
write on the book and ruin it
yeah that so if they want to tape it on
the inside they can so it's technically
i did sign it if they care about that if
not they could wipe their ass with it
too yeah please wipe your ass with it
nobody cares and i put a little bit more
extra swag in there just because you
know
winners winners deserve a lot of stuff
so we went to grandma's house to pick up
the monkey dude and now we just parked
at jimby
and he's out cold
see him snoring
i gotta fix his neck oh my god
how uncomfortable okay hold on
that's better
thank you papa you're welcome what is
this one this is the new guava yes oh
yes oh yes oh yes yes yes
i [ __ ] love it
what is this game again minecraft
that's real life
big minecraft what does that do
you can beat them up okay let's get them
up go ahead
okay
come on come here okay well they do that
um i just want to catch you up on
something real quick
so you know tracking my macros
um i'm tracking my caloric intake which
means i
well macronutrients protein
carbohydrates and um carbs
wait protein carbs and fats
um so the junebe matcha drink i love it
it was so perfect and we do this
in-house
homemade or business made
guava peri so all the ingredients high
quality fresh
but
if we know about nutrition that we know
that um boba carbs
sugar carbs
fruit carbs so that entire drink was
nothing but a big ass carb and of course
i had to drink the whole thing but
because i drank the whole thing i maxed
out my carbs let me show you what it
looks like it looks ridiculous
where is my phone
oh here it is
okay
so
and i spilled it on my shirt
i mean that's the least of my worries
okay
so let me
okay so these are my numbers
so i'm supposed to hit a daily
um
174 grams of carbs oops
there we go 174 grams of carbs
um
42 grams of fat and 179
grams of protein
oh and you notice how i went over
already
by whoops
to
2 grams
so all i can have right now are things
that are
high in fat
or relatively high 27 grams high and 133
grams
of protein left that i have to fill
so i have to look for things that don't
have carbs which means i'm only eating
protein
and how much fat do i have
so fat
let me see does an avocado
have carbs
i'm learning a lot of stuff ah
of course that has carbs it's a [ __ ]
fruit what the hell was i thinking
what do i do
so that's 12 grams of carbs but the fat
is great it's 22 grams of fat
so the question is
as i'm talking to you this is happening
in front of me
oh no oh no an invisible man is beating
him up no
what
so i have a dilemma here
i am going to eat um
some swag which i was like why would i
do that it's so long in fact
but whatever um i'll do that
some shrimp which is also low in fat
oh i know why i'm doing it because i
can't have carbs i need to be satiated
aka i need to feel full for the rest of
the night
so i'm gonna try to hit that
hundred and something left
i'll figure it out and i'll report back
but in the meantime
this is what's happening over here
papa's now on the floor
what is happening i was dead but now
it's round two oh okay
so i found what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna make some shrimp fish
use some
salt free
mrs dash
this one is just original flavor i'm
gonna eat some i'm gonna put some
monterey jack cheese on it because check
it out ate fat zero carb
smells like feet
and i'm gonna cook in
butter
one tablespoon is seven grams
of fat so i can cook with one tablespoon
and about
[Applause]
uh almost half a cup
[Applause]
we're back in business baby
so bam
there it is my butter shrimp with some
lemon and my little god and butter and
limon
so i couldn't eat uh the cheese because
um when i went to get it it was actually
moldy so no cheese i just added a little
bit more butter and it worked
this guy over here look at that
i'll ask you about it later okay i'm
gonna eat right now
absolutely look at it look at it
it just diet friendly though just let
you know
it is we'll talk about it i just want to
eat my warm food
and take a finished all his dumplings
you people
sorry forgot to film all the ingredients
that were in bart's macro friendly
noodle soup but don't worry he did a
whole reel on it on his instagram so go
to barbra kwan you'll see it there he
tells you what to buy how to prepare
that whole line
i'm outside right now with taika
it's been about two days since that last
footage that you saw of us eating dinner
um because a lot the day afterwards
we trained in the morning when i came
back home i was about to take a shower
and taika ended up having another
seizure
so this
what we thought because we still weren't
sure and the
you know the test came back inconclusive
uh we kind of just tracked it up as
dehydration or something
with the first seizure but it's been
confirmed that he does get seizures now
and he did get one and it was
terrifying when i tell you it was
terrifying it was terrifying i was in
the shower do you remember monkey when
you had your seizure
or when you fainted again you don't
remember
right now he has a bloody nose has
nothing to do with
the seizure but um
yeah we're still in california
i was literally in the shower i had
probably been there for maybe like five
minutes or less
and i hear like the kids outside
kind of going back and forth because i
had the window open
um
yeah the neighbor kids yeah
um and then out of nowhere i hear my mom
going geo geo call 9-1-1 called 9-1-1
and i was like
butt ass naked and i'm like what what do
you mean she was taika he's he's choking
he's not breathing he's not breathing
so then
i come out and i see taika's lifeless
body
i didn't see his mouth blue or anything
and i just hear bart going taika daiko
wake up wake up and he's giving him the
heimlich
uh maneuver
yeah kind of
it was
terrifying
couldn't hear the operator i just i
don't know what they were saying i'm
like this is the address just get here
he's not breathing we didn't know what
was going on um before anything had
happened he was eating like some chips
or something so we all thought he had
something lodged in his head i mean in
his throat
um within like five minutes cops come
rushing in
taika is just lifeless
incoherent
it was so scary
now he's full of life
can you talk to me oh talk to who then
okay go talk yes
i see something bumpy
see something bumpy and orange
oh you found a treasure dude
[Applause]
okay
what's in there
[Applause]
is it your witch's bruise still
okay can you give me two minutes i'm
gonna say something i'm gonna finish my
story okay
okay
yeah so i mean you can just imagine
thinking your one and only child
is losing their life right in front of
you because we honestly thought there's
something in there yep
that something was lodged in there and
he couldn't breathe because he just was
blue and lifeless
so they come pick them up ambulance
comes
a bunch of questions we take them to the
uh
er
they treat them and then he's slowly
coming through and i'm starting to
recognize the patterns again of the
first time he had a seizure when we
picked him up and everything was
you know kind of pointing in the
direction of another seizure
um and then within like 20 minutes he
was back to his normal self and it is in
fact he did have another seizure um
we're still in california now
this happened like i said like two days
ago but monitoring him because now this
is his second seizure
we do have an au we do have him on
medication he takes it in the day and in
the night now so that should keep
seizures at big
we don't know
what it is
or um what's causing it it can be
genetic it can be so many things
um
seizures as far as i know
doesn't run in my family um
it also doesn't run in
my uh bart's family so we just don't
really know what's going on
so as soon as we get home next week um
we're gonna get all the testing done all
over again
and then just take it from there um let
his
school know so they know how to treat it
just in case and they know how to
yucky
and they know how to um
look for it they they leave him less
uh at least someone will be around him a
little bit more
um the day i found out that it was a
seizure which is the same day the
seizure happened i rounded up my whole
family and i gave everyone a tutorial of
what to do
in case he has another seizure and i
think it'd be really cool if you know
because i didn't know before this
[Applause]
it's kind of sad like i'm for sure
because
if you've never seen it
it's
pretty intense
yeah
and it's just sad because you know he's
a baby
and i know he's technically not a baby
but he's a little kid you know and like
i didn't have to go through any of this
you know thank god and and neither did
bart
and it's just
you know it's always a bummer seeing
your kids go through medical things you
know and you kind of wish you can
take place of
whatever they're going through like you
wish you could take their place um
but for whatever reason it's
he's going through it you know um
but
i just want to share with you guys
one what's been happening and two what
to do in case you're around someone that
has a seizure because um
it's a scary thing and it's intense
but i feel like if we're all equipped
with the right tools of how to care for
someone that's having a seizure or had a
seizure um
it makes it less daunting and scary and
less of an emergency
so
what i learned
the type of
seizures that we've seen taika have and
they're all gonna vary
so like we've already seen him i've seen
him do like a little shake
um but they can also just start drooling
and kind of look like they're on pause
uh they could start speaking gibberish
like a seizure will look different
every time
but when that happens if they do so
happen to fall you want to make sure if
you're around at least that you can
catch their fall because
they won't be able to break their fall
so they might hit their head
if they are on the floor already you
want to make sure that they're
not around anything where they could
potentially hurt themselves because they
are moving
and they're not quite coherent um you
want to get them away from anything
sharp or anything loose or anything
sharp
like a sharp knife you thought i was
talking about sharks um you want to put
them on their side
the side that you put them on doesn't
matter because
it
because they're drooling and sometimes
they may even vomit
sometimes they may lose control of their
batter bladder and they might peek
but
specifically to
the drooling or the vomit you don't want
to lay them on their back because then
that creates a pool and they can start
choking on that so when that happens
you want to lay them on their side so
that they're safe and they don't choke
um
you also don't want to stop them from
shaking you don't want to restrain them
so that they stop moving just let them
go through what they need to go through
yep as soon as you see the seizure
happen just keep in mind don't do that
to grandma's plants please i'll need
that no you don't no no no don't do that
um you just want to make sure that um
if you have a clock or a watch i should
say or if there's a clock around you or
um if there's a phone if you have a
phone just look at what time the seizure
started
normally if the seizure is
anywhere from a few seconds to
uh five minutes you're no real emergency
anything lasting longer than emergency
you do want to call 9-1-1
and let them know immediately to come
and get this person that's still having
a seizure
um
because their muscles are going to tense
up
they might get blue in the face and in
the mouth
but they are in fact breathing but it's
just the amount of breath that they can
take in because their muscles are so
tense all over the body it's not like
they can expand their lungs because of
the
tension in the muscle so instead of them
going
like what we can do when our muscles are
loose
because theirs is tense they could only
take
small
breaths so it does look scary but they
are in fact breathing
um you don't want to stick anything in
their mouth what i was told back in the
day was that they might swallow their
tongue so you want to put something in
their mouth so that they don't swallow
their tongue and that's
not correct um you don't want to put
anything in their mouth
you have to eat
okay
um
you don't want to eat that yeah and you
want to just say positive encouraging
words and
you know for the next few minutes they
might not be aware of one what happened
who they are like in tiger's case
he can't even talk
he can't say anything
um he starts crying
um he doesn't remember anything
he tries to ha but if he tries to talk
at nighttime
and i don't know what he's saying
at the end of it too he gets really
really tired because his body just went
through something pretty
pretty traumatic i guess
so he will like be
extremely exhausted
so i let him sleep
and i just give him nothing but
encouraging
positive words and
that's kind of it you just let them go
through it and
you're just there holding their hand
yeah i'm just doing that
if you can and if you can you just leave
them alone but
you just let them know that they're not
alone and you're there and
just remain positive and
look at the time
and that's kind of it
yeah you wanna hold your hand
when you walk
i'll go over there and look at this but
i'm so happy to see him like this
over there and i get a scoop of
that and yeah okay
um but now i know if it gets a little
too quiet or if he's acting abnormal
then
it's highly likely he's having a seizure
i've been doing a ton of research i
cooked it i eat it you ate it what did
it taste like it tastes like poop
okay
um
and i've been listening to lectures
and research and stuff and some do say
and i don't you know i take this with a
grain of salt i i'm not banking on it
but some do say that some kids
my grandma gave me chocolate and then
and that was in the sun i have to yeah
no thank you
[Music]
he's been working on this bridge which
is brew for
weeks
there is moon pies what's in here
moon pies french fries
napkins rice dirt
old flowers
you told me you always tell me
there's a bunch of crap in there but
um
yeah just have to keep an eye on him
just a little bit more
i don't want to change anything in his
life
um other than just
adding more helmets here and there
um
keeping my ears open a little bit more
and my eyes open
and
that's kind of all i can do
uber eats is here lunch
grandma got him some popeyes
oh grandma wants today do you want to
buy some food
you want to buy some chicken strips
that's how taker plays with this guy is
playing with
but yeah um
nothing changes he's a regular dude
he just has some special things about
him
but we all do this is spicy okay
and that's kind of it
i'm sorry y'all
this is such a
downer way to end this vlog but know
that i don't see this situation
as a downer i just see it as
just another thing i gotta
check off every day right like did he
take his medication that's it i'm not
like i mentioned earlier outside i'm not
gonna treat him differently nothing's
gonna change in our family he's the
coolest dude ever he's the monkiest dude
ever
um we're just gonna live our normal
lives this doesn't hold us back in any
way
yeah
i don't know i always believe everything
happens for a reason
and the universe or god or whatever it
is that you believe in
um
just sends us things our way that are
meant to be for us you know um it's a
gift that is given to us and we decide
if we want to add negative connotation
to it or a positive
meaning to it um
and i refuse to
take things negatively ever
i always feel like there's a lesson in
everything that happens and and things
just happen
you know it's us who add
you know the tone of it's negative or
it's positive like it just is
do you know what i mean
so this is one of those things that just
is
and i'm gonna choose to
take away as much as i possibly can from
it and look at this i've been able to
share how to treat someone
that's having a seizure with you guys
like it's already having a positive
influence so now you guys hopefully feel
well equipped when you do see something
like this that you don't panic and
you're gonna be like hey i remember judo
says that
you know let's just look at my phone
make sure it's not you know how long
this seizure is gonna last just put them
on their side
speak to them with love and kindness and
positivity and be by their side until
they come through and that's it
you know so a lot of positive can come
from this and i'm just going to view it
that way so thank you guys so much for
supporting
i'm always going to keep you guys
updated
i will definitely keep you posted on his
you know whatever's happening in his
life um and if you have any questions
for me ever hit me up um either in the
comments or if you want to reach me a
little bit faster just hit me up in the
dms and i'm more than happy to not
interact with you guys so until then
bye